nos dicen las funciones diferenciables x
y james están relacionadas por la
siguiente ecuación james es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de x y esto es bastante
interesante porque aquí ambas funciones
tanto x como james son funciones
diferenciables incluso x es una función
ojo debe de ser una función de algo más
y después nos dicen además la derivada
de x con respecto a t es igual a 12 y
nos preguntan encuentran la derivada de
ye con respecto a tema cuanto x es igual
a 9 así que antes de empezar déjame ver
si estamos seguros de que entendemos el
problema nos dicen que tanto x como jim
estas dos son funciones
ambas son funciones de temp y puedes ver
que es una función de x pero x es una
función del tiempo y por lo tanto
podemos decir que james es una función
del tiempo una forma de verlo es la
siguiente
vemos que x es una función del tiempo ok
y sabemos que ya es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de x bueno entonces puedo decir
que ya es igual a la raíz cuadrada de
esta función del tiempo ok ahora esa es
una forma de verlo otra forma de verlo
es la siguiente si tú tienes a t ok y lo
metes en la función
efe lo que vas a obtener es a equis y
sea esta x ahora la metes en esta
función llamada raíz cuadrada estará
aquí entonces lo que obtienes es a jr
y por lo tanto si ves todo esto como una
caja grandota entonces podemos decir que
es una función de ok así que ahora vamos
a responder nuestra pregunta y para
responderla tenemos que aplicar la regla
de la cadena y la regla de la cadena lo
que nos dice es que la derivada de con
respecto a t que es justo lo que
buscamos déjame escribirlo es igual a la
derivada de que con respecto a x
por la derivada de x con respecto al
tiempo ok entonces vamos a tener que la
derivada de jeff con respecto a t va a
ser igual a la derivada de con respecto
a x ok pero sabemos que james es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de x o lo podemos
escribir como que james es igual a x
elevado a la un medio y ahora sí si
queremos la derivada de ye con respecto
a x ahora podemos utilizar la regla de
la potencia es decir esta derivada va a
ser igual a bajamos la potencia y me
queda un medio que multiplica a x
elevado a la menos 1 medio
ok vamos a escribirlo por acá un médium
que multiplica a x elevado a la menos un
médium ok y esto que va a multiplicar a
la derivada de x con respecto al tiempo
la derivada de x con respecto a tm ok
entonces lo que nosotros queremos es la
derivada de con respecto al tiempo que
es justo lo que tenemos aquí y esto va a
ser igual déjame ponerlo va a ser igual
y ahora observa nos dan el dato de
cuánto vale la derivada de x con
respecto a temps me dicen que es 12
entonces lo voy a poner aquí y me dicen
que x vale 9 por lo tanto lo voy a poner
aquí sustituyendo sus valores me va a
quedar que un medio que multiplica a 9
porque es lo que vale x x vale 9 elevado
a la menos un medio
la derivada de que es con respecto a t
que por cierto me dicen que es 12 esto
va a ser igual a la derivada del yen con
respecto al ok ahora hay que resolver
esto pero es muy sencillo porque sabemos
que el 9 elevado a la un médium es 3
entonces 9 elevado a la menos un medio
esto es lo mismo que un tercio
tercio ok ir se multiplicó un medio por
un tercio bueno eso me queda un sexto
entonces esto va a ser igual a tener
como denominador a seis y como numerador
bueno a 12 a 12 entonces esto me va a
quedar igual a 12 entre 6 lo cual es 2 y
de lujo este es el resultado que
buscábamos
es decir la derivada de ye con respecto
al tema cuando x toma el valor de 9 y
cuando la derivada de x con respecto a
tema es igual a 12 hasta la próxima